[Music]
this is star talk i'm your host neil
degrass tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're doing
cosmic queries we're going to start off
in the first segment with a grab bag and
my
guest co-host today is jordan klemper
did i get you saying
yes
take it slow i know this is tough
there's a lot there's consonants there's
syllables in there
it takes a while we're going to get
through this
questions about a gravitational field
this is the this is the easy part dale
so jude i missed you we haven't had you
on the show all since covid so it's been
a while i've been waiting i've
i've had nothing to do neil i've had
nothing to do please
sour bread children all sorts of stuff
thank you it's called sour dough bread
not sour bread just i i haven't been
paying attention to what the kids are
into these days i just and you also
cranked out a covet baby very
congratulations congratulations and
you're still a correspondent at the
daily show yes uh
still going out into the field
talking to
uh people who are anti-vaxx anti-mask
anti-science exposing the irrationality
of the world
this
i need this
neil ability to have an articulate
conversation about things that aren't
happening on this planet is
excellent well
let's do this and we've got a grab bag
of questions for this one so there's
gonna be a potpourri and you've had the
questions i haven't seen them if i don't
know the answer i'll just say i don't
know go to the next one
and so give it to me and tell us who
asked the question as well we know
they're all from patreon who are our
most devoted supporters
and so
kudos to you patriotics do they have a
name do we have a is that shorthand
oh no we don't that i like that the
patriotics it sounds like an old-school
r b group
[Music]
yeah give it up for gladys knight in the
patriotics
yeah she moved past the pit they were
asking for too much money the patriotics
let's bring them in
i love it i love it our first patriotic
is sandra pagliani and she wants to know
knowing what we know
now do you think we have all that we
need to be able to safely send humans to
mars today if not
what are we missing yeah so a great
question so the answer is yes
no one is saying we can't go to mars
because we can't figure it out that is
not the issue the issue is it's
expensive do people want to do it for
that much money
and there'll be dangers because there'll
be some unknowns and some unknown
unknowns we get it but the probably the
last thing that we haven't fully figured
out but if you task some engineers to it
they'll be on it i'm not worried about
this is when you leave the protective
magnetic blanket
that we enjoy here on earth's surface
that shields us from some ionizing
radiation from the sun the sun is a very
active place the solar wind has all
these charged particles that are not
good for human physiology the atmosphere
and the magnetic field protects us from
that you leave that and go on a long
voyage
then you are now susceptible so we need
radiation protection along the way
that's and so the engineers would figure
that out to figure out what materials by
the way you know what absorbs that
radiation water
so imagine a spaceship where there's a
there's a
there's a layer of protective water that
cycles through you
okay
so you would drink it you pee it out or
go filter it go back in
so so you'd have this this system where
life-sustaining water is also your
shield then you get to mars
mars doesn't have a magnetic field to
protect it so you just you need to like
live underground or something
okay you feel confident that we just
throw some engineers at that and they
can figure it out i i there's still not
the technology to figure out how to send
me to phoenix safely
i've tried spf i've tried thick clothing
my body doesn't withstand the heat
yeah phoenix latest research is like a
quarter mile from the surface of the sun
so you need special spf 1 billion for
that uh yeah so yeah i think engineers
what they need is
what is what is the challenge how much
money do you have and how much time do
you have
okay and then that's where
feeds the engineer and they solve
problems that previously might have
thought to be intractable so i so that's
where so we don't have a field we don't
have discovery without engineers sitting
in the next room helping us figure out
how to build the thing so yeah there's
nothing in the way except money
so
we're basically there in a capitalistic
society consider us on mars
uh well that's that's the little
i would say
a a capitalist society with vision
and
a sense of wonder and exploration we're
we're already on mars
let's hear from our next patriotic this
is tj monroe he says dr tyson
could you explain the relationship
between the plane of our solar system
and the plane of our galaxy i know that
our sun is moving south
but how does that relate to the galactic
disk
oh okay yeah so we so so the sun's
x the sun's spin axis and the disc in
which all the planets orbit
except pluto
which is tipped
30 degrees out of the plane of all the
other planets that's another reason we
never even listed for you why pluto
never
pluto had it coming okay so and just
you got to get off the pluto thing all
right the patriotics have spoken it's
time to move on from the pluto tag
moveon.org
so
uh so the the angle that this the solar
system makes to the plane of the galaxy
it's like what is it 90
uh it's it's more than fully tipped
and so
we're actually sort of dragging through
the galaxy as we orbit it takes a couple
hundred million years to complete an
orbit but here's what's cool the cool
part is as
as the solar system moves through the
galaxy
if you track the paths through space
that the planets are making
it's a
corkscrew through the fabric of space
and time
because we're going around the sun but
we're also moving sideways to it
so if you combine circular motion with
motion sideways you get a corkscrew and
so all the planets are corkscrewing
around the sun as it moves it through
the galaxy it's a beautiful thing to
watch when you see it mapped out you
could also say it's like a toilet bowl
but then it wouldn't be a beautiful
thing i i guess
we spoke corkscrew was the right call
that's what i'm saying yeah i think so
yeah i'm good i'm sticking with the
corkscrew
on that yeah uh this is from rick
carlson
hi dr tyson and friends because i'm
gonna i'm one of the friends clepper is
how it's pronounced
clapper because we can detect
gravitational waves from massive
astronomical events ligo and virgo that
obviously didn't tear the place up is
there a distance from the events that
would be considered safe but would still
allow you to notice slash felix
you know i never thought about that
because
you occupy a volume in the fabric of
space and time
and a gravitational wave washes over you
distorting the fabric of space and time
but you are occupying the space and time
so how would you know
if you had a wave move across you
if you become part of the wave that
moves across you
that's i don't have an answer for that
so you ever see a duck sitting on the uh
on the ocean and then a wave comes by
the dog just goes up and down right does
the duck even know or care that it's a
wave went under it and so
i don't know that you would feel it
i'd have to think about that
this is this is why i get stoned before
doing these things
no no think about it consider you have
an aunt
walking on a sheet of paper okay and the
answer is just mine is something and you
take the piece of paper and curve it
the ant is just still walking
does it even know or care that you put
curvature
in its universe you would have no idea
if you're the ant
and so unless you made it like a kink in
it then it would have to sort of then
the kink is a is like is is sharp
compared to its own body but if it's a
wave moving through i i i wonder if we
would notice at all and you need the
special instruments to make this
measurement that's why
that's why so you're measuring at two
right angles all right and so you look
at what the length of one of these is
relative to the length of the other as
the wave moves across it because it
stretches in one direction and not the
other and for you to notice that
i don't i don't know
is that that's a good question i don't
have a firm answer for it
but nor do i want to do the experiment
to find out
you don't want to ride that wave
yeah yeah no i don't want to arrive that
way no no no uh let's check in with
roman precop
uh okay roman roman says is there any
scientific reason for the shape of the
enterprise ship if it is just an
artistic impression would it actually
hold up as an effective shape out there
yeah so first of all
all these aerodynamic shapes in space
completely pointless because there's no
aerodynamics in space so they're cool
and badass looking okay
but that ship was built in dry dock in
space and launched from space so it
didn't have to move through our
atmosphere to get there right whereas
the space shuttle the orbiter because it
had to actually come out of orbit and
navigate throughout air
there's some air surfaces on it it's got
wings it's got a nose cone it's got
things that matter when you're moving
through the air so the the enterprise
badass as it looks did not have to be
that bad it could have been just an
angular thing
that it could look like anything and
would have been no less effective
achieving warp speeds
so here's a question i'm going to add on
to this for you neil yeah so in this
world where the enterprise is being
built in space
from a more
um advanced civilization time period
wise
they have the technology to build the
enterprise do you think the people at
that time even though they could build a
more functional
ship the people at that time would still
need an aesthetically cool ship to want
to support such a project
yes
[Laughter]
because you want people to like rally
around it you want it to feel like the
future and future stuff has to look
badass otherwise
what's going to motivate you what's
going to do
so i'm i'm into design i love design i
love good design i love design that says
yeah i want to be in that i want to i
want i want to i want to be a part of
that future
because what what is the future if not
something that doesn't look like
anything we've ever designed before
do you think human beings will ever
evolve past the need for design to be
uh over function or is that inherent to
us as humans oh yeah that's a good
question i know that you know once we
control the human genome you can put
more of it in or take it out i guess
i don't know i know some people who
don't care about design at all we all
know such people
they're not following the latest
fashions or trends or anything and
they're just living all right and that
that's cool that's cool but we happen to
live in a world where there are people
that care about what things look like
and i'm glad some of them are designing
our spaceship
so jordan we're going to take a break
and when we come back we're going to
bring in nicole stott who has a new book
on what earth looks like from space
because guess what
she's been in space okay
and uh she's also an artist and thinks a
lot about the effects of having these
views of the universe on one's
creativity so we're going to look into
that and continue cosmic queries into
those topics when star talk returns
we're back star talk cosmic queries
edition and i got my co-host jordan
clapper jordan
let's bring your friends neil
okay
jordan do you have a social media
presence why don't you tell us what that
is do i have a social media presence i
think i'm i'm all over that place you
can you can get at me at twitter at
jordanclepper get at me at instagram
also my name um yeah jordan clepper very
clever they both have the same handle
exactly you know i you got to be clever
with this kind of thing it's it's a nice
chance i just it's an invitation to see
more of my life and my insights and at
home we love your dispatches on on on
comedy central's uh daily show so keep
those going that's right and what that
means is if the day that rationality
takes over the world you won't have a
job because the people
well once once this world becomes a
rational peaceful place i'm out of work
but until then business is booming
business is booming
all right so in this segment we're
bringing in nicole stott nicole is an
engineer and artist and and a retired
nasa astronaut
put in 104 days in space so that's up
there doing some stuff
and also i for i remember we had these
at nasa aquanaut
all right spending 18 days underwater in
the aquarius undersea laboratory very
pleased to know that we're doing some
some work there at the bottom of the
ocean
and but here's what i love about it uh
nicole you're the first person to
paint in watercolor in space
what's up with that and tell me about
this
space for art foundation that you're
director of
yeah thanks great great to be here with
you guys and
uh yeah painting in space uh i don't
know that i would have figured out to do
that on my own uh one of our our people
that i thank every time i see her mary
jane anderson
you know she is the person who helps us
put all of our stuff together that we're
going to take to space and
and she encouraged me she's like you
know nicole you're going to be living
there not just working there bring
something with you that you enjoy doing
on earth and so i chose watercolors well
it's something that fits in a small bag
not a tuba
there are others who have you know
gotten away with bringing keyboards and
guitars and other things up there but
peloton the peloton might not make a cut
exactly yeah and but it was awesome
because you know i think about it now in
hindsight it's like man that's what we
need to do to put the human and human
space flight right we need to recognize
that we're living there we need to bring
our humanity with us that should be
stuff that we enjoy and you should enjoy
yourself
when you're in space on a spaceship but
you know as well as here on earth and
well is this part of the themes that fed
your latest book back to earth what life
in space taught me about our home planet
and our mission to protect it because
that all sounds like it's drawn from the
same thematic pot yeah i think so you
know i you know we go and you guys talk
about this all the time complexities
that are just beyond my total
understanding but for
for us to fly in space to live and work
in there even for a short period of time
it's a pretty complex thing but for me
in the end it all came down to like
simple lessons like oh my gosh we live
on a planet
who knew you know we're all we're we're
waiting nicole we we have to spend 100.
no no you didn't have to spend a million
dollars to put you in space to tell me
we live on the planet really
there's taxpayers listening to this
right the taxpayers listen
now right
we gotta use that money for the american
education system clearly
we all know these things right we know
we live on a planet we know we're
earthlings we know that the only border
that really matters is that thin blue
line of atmosphere and yet that time and
space for me made that really real to me
made me realize that wow we are doing
things
complex things as an international
community peacefully successfully on
this mechanical life support system
that is the international space station
national space station we've built it
right to mimic as best we can what earth
does for us naturally
and
it's just the most wonderful example for
how we should be living like crewmates
here on spaceship earth
and that i mean that really became the
reality of it for me what are the ways
we do that in space you know as the crew
of six or seven
on the space station the tens of
thousands of people across the agencies
here on earth that we can share that
might encourage people to behave that
way
as crewmates and not passengers uh wait
so what does art have to do with it and
plus i'm a little worried because that
that thing hanging behind you on the
wall does was that a spacesuit that an
artist got a hold of that you know this
thing is awesome so you asked about the
space for art foundation and
i i painted in space came back to earth
thinking okay i'm going to use after
retiring from nasa i'm going to use my
artwork to share the experience right
get people knowing about all this work
we're doing in space that's ultimately
about improving life on earth
and that evolved into working with kids
and hospitals and refugee centers around
the world and creating these really
i mean they are works of art
art spacesuits and
partnering with uh teams like the folks
here at ilc dover the space suit company
who
quilt these kids art together for us
that's where you are in this moment
that's where i am right now yeah really
um kind of cool today you know as a as a
even as a former astronaut it's like any
time you can get in a spacesuit that's a
good day
hey i got to do that got to get in one
of the new designs and move around and
see what it's going to be like and
imagine myself walking around on the
moon or mars
so so you're not the first astronaut to
bring art to the forefront of people's
attention we go back to the apollo era
we get to alan bean i mean he published
books on art so
is the art something that
should we be sending more artists into
space because they would communicate a
different kind of life experience than
an engineer would
and you have the benefit of being both
yeah i think and i what's interesting to
me is i've kind of through my nasa
career watch the people around me and
try to get a sense of you know what they
enjoy the kinds of things they're doing
outside of the technical work area
and i think for most of us there's some
creative outlet and you know you
mentioned alan being um apollo fourth
guy to walk on the moon who comes back
retires from nasa and paints the
experience for people
you can go back even further to alexei
leonov who wanted to be an artist before
he wanted to be a cosmonaut and took
colored pencils with him and sketched
you know sketched orbital sunrises drew
portraits during the apollo soyuz
mission and
my friend karen nyberg who quilted in
space and al warden who wrote poetry i
mean it's just in us to want to
you know to want to share the experience
in different ways and and i'm absolutely
open we should be sending artists we
should be send in
you know all satirical comedians
we should be sending jordan
i tell you what you're describing you go
away just to understand that the earth
is beneath us you get to quilt you get
to paint a little bit i feel like this
sounds like an ayahuasca trip and i am
in yeah and we need it we'll need some
earth jokes you know when we get back
new material for that for that stand-up
routine you got going
so nicole your book is back to earth
what life in space taught me about our
home planet and our mission to protect
it and we solicited questions for you
from our fan base from our patreon fan
base and in this program uh jordan has
renamed this community that what did you
call them jordan it's the patriotics the
patriotics ladies and
so here we go they're they're our most
loyal supporters and they get to get
their questions asked submit and
submitted and answered so jordan what do
you have for us i got i got ben moore
and ben wants to know he says uh hi dr
tyson and nicole my question is for
nicole and i was wondering if you could
give us an insight into what it's truly
like to look back at earth from space
it's been a dream of mine and i can
barely begin to comprehend what that
must be like thanks for your time and
nicole before you answer that let me
just i have to put this in there are
people who are going in the
the suborbital sort of joyride the
billionaire joyrides and
to a schoolroom globe they went up the
thickness of two dimes
okay i did the math on that and so and
so not even in orbit and even that low
is there some distance above which you
do feel
like yeah i'm an astronaut and i'm
looking down on earth rather than i'm
just in a very high airplane
you know i don't know what that number
would be i'd like to think that the
folks that flew on you know on the
virgin and on the blue origin flight
had their face in the window long enough
to really let it soak in let it quit the
little flippy do's and look back at
earth um
with the zero g flippy dudes yes okay
i mean you know don't use your five
minutes that way
i can tell you nothing prepared me for
what i was gonna see what i was gonna
feel how it was gonna get in me
this this sense of our home as a planet
as one place in space um
i described to my son who was seven when
i flew the first time i'm like oh my
gosh roman
imagine that you've got the brightest
light bulb you've ever seen you've
splattered it with all the colors you
know earth to be it's against the
blackest deepest black
backdrop that you've ever seen and now
you turn that light bulb on and you
almost you have to kind of look away and
adjust because it just
glows with this iridescence and
translucence and the and and you
i don't know i mean i was the farthest
i've ever been from home and i felt more
connected
to that place and everything below me
than i had necessarily ever felt with my
feet right on it and i want people so
so nicole can you tell me an imax movie
can't do that for you
you know it i there's a sense of it
because that's cheaper that's cheaper
than going to the space station i'd like
to see all of our leaders get to space
and bounce their heads around in the
window you know
better than glasgow in
november how about we get them on a
station with their faces in the window
but i don't think you have to go to
space to
know these things to feel these things
to appreciate the on wonder that
surrounds us every day and i think
looking up
you know looking up to the sky is uh is
an equally
stunning and compelling way to get that
sense as looking back at earth is
okay cool cool all right jordan what
else you got for us we got we got brian
lacy here uh brian says art is the
expression of emotional power what
object in the universe makes you feel
emotional power wow emotional power wow
i i you know i think i
would have to come back to
this this view of earth this um
you know this sense of of home that
comes from that and i don't i don't know
i think it's emotionally powerful i
don't know if necessarily gives me
emotional but it's emotionally powerful
and and you guys yeah you're powerful on
you is different from feeling power
right right that's a different thing so
is it humbling oh my gosh absolutely
yeah absolutely and you know you you you
know the this this
almost unfathomable size of our universe
what we know of the universe the sense
of oh we're this tiny little dot kind of
thing and the grand scheme and that
always worried me that there i'd have
this feeling of insignificance
associated with that
absolutely not i mean thinking about our
planet
perfectly placed from the sun you know
distance like doing all it needs to do
like it's the spaceship to take care of
us
that's significant to me
that we're meeting each other today
because there's some significance in all
of this that's going on around us in
this place and
that's i don't know that's a pretty
powerful emotionally powerful thing to
consider
so your your book has a new age chapter
then
grounded chapter yes
[Laughter]
we're all spiritually connected
okay all right i'll tell you what object
makes me
feel emotionally powerful and wields
power over me it makes me feel
insignificant it's it's instagram
instagram
like i think immediately we need top
people to look into that yes exactly
instagram effects
nothing yes you you stare at it and yet
you feel small in comparison to the your
friends who went to tulum
all right keep them coming what do you
have uh this is from chester lipschitz
would it even be practical to use the
mediums we use today to create art in
zero gravity as in orbit or low gravity
such as mars would we have to develop a
whole new set of materials to continue
to use our human creativity to express
the environment that surrounds us i love
that yeah what role does zero g play in
your artwork or or even like 40 percent
g what you get on mars
i think we will i think we will
try to continue using the same medium
that we have
and then we'll just realize that that
environment allows us to do a lot more
creative things with it and i mean i
even found that on the space station you
know i didn't have a cup of water that i
could dip my brush into i had to squirt
a little ball of water out and watch it
floating and you know go to dip the
brush and then and maybe you guys can
once and for all somebody can explain to
me but that floating ball of water even
before
the tip of the brush touched it it's
like it wanted to move on to the end of
the brush and then i'm watching this
floating ball of water under the brush
and i move it down to the paints and the
paint's kind of pulled it away and
you know in my simple mind i'm thinking
what's this super mysterious
attraction thing that's going on between
these materials yeah surface tension
yeah
i
that's that's really really cool you
know
and
and i tried to paint the way i paint on
earth and yet if i touch the brush to
the paper that whole blob of colored
water would go into the paper and i'd
start over and it turned out so your
tactics have to be different you know
and you're floating and everything has
to be organized and i found i was just
like dragging the colored water along
the paper to create so in some way okay
so what we need to see is your we need
to see your first painting that's the
one where you're adjusting i wish i had
activated my brain cell to not throw
those things away
my first painting in zero g that's what
that is yeah and another little point
unappreciated perhaps is on the moon or
or on mars you can construct sculptures
that are
multiple times larger than you can on
earth because they don't weigh as much
and so they won't sort of structurally
they can hold themselves up to to larger
sizes and so yeah i see what we do
but but you have to send the artist
and the one comedian you have to do that
just
please to critique the art right yeah
yeah so so jordan here's a here's a joke
for you for when they send you to the
moon
and say um i love their restaurants
there they were they were wonderful
great food but they had no atmosphere
okay that that that's a gift to you
your first joke in the in the nightclub
is this thing on is this
does electricity work up here actually i
don't know uh is this room dead uh oh it
is it's been oh okay all right okay uh
let's see if we can squeeze one more
question in before we take a quick break
go ahead great
uh this is from uh gabriella
dighoffs hi nicole as a female engineer
it's so impressive to see another fellow
female being an astronaut for nasa in a
male-dominated industry only 65 out of
565 total astronauts have been women
what was it like for you throughout your
career to be a female in the industry
and do you have any advice for young
female engineers which we'll get to
after this break
see what i did there i created the
suspense
i also felt like you were like let's
keep it short and i asked a question
what's it like to be one of those i said
we have a few seconds left to get in a
question i know your question is
nicole
yeah nicole answer that in three words
please when we come back
[Laughter]
we will answer that very important
question about sort of gender parity in
space exploration and in the engineering
community when star talk returns
we're back with nicole stott who's our
engineer artist
astronaut in the house and who's now
coming to us from planet houston
where
the from a whole company that thinks
about innovative designs of spacesuits
and you've got one behind you that where
an artist got a hold of it it looks like
lots of little artists yeah lots of
little artists got a hold of it jordan
klepper left left off with a
brilliant and important and incisive
question uh could you just read that
back again real quick jordan yeah in a
nutshell this is again this is from
gabriella uh who's also a female
engineer she wonders what it was like
for you throughout your career to be a
female in the industry and do you have
any advice for young yeah excellent and
especially given the the the prevalence
of males in in such an industry and what
struggles or challenges you had to
overcome
yeah it is a great question and you know
first i'll say i felt it all along
really fortunate because
i think when i came into nasa
as a young engineer in the late 80s
already there was this push there was
the group i came in with
half of us were young women um coming in
we were getting back up and running with
the shuttle program we're working in the
hangar you know getting the vehicles
ready to fly
and there was just a presence there
already and um
which by the way was a huge shift from
the previous generation of anything we
thought of who would be an astronaut
right yeah that was a whole a whole new
era for for nasa yeah you know it's
from within nasa at least from the human
space flight side of things there's been
a real progress over these you know 50
or so years to where i mean what we've
been celebrating the apollo
anniversaries 50th anniversaries of all
the apollo missions right and when you
look back at that and you look in
mission control there were no women in
the front room poppy northcutt was in
the back room doing some really you know
important stuff
at launch control in florida at kennedy
sp there was one woman joanne morgan
smack dab in the middle of the launch
control center and now
at nasa in mission control and launch
control both of those places are run by
really incredible women and when you
look across the consoles you're just
seeing this this mix of humanity you're
not as it as as it should have been from
the beginning yeah and it's a really
impressive thing and it kind of is
pervasive across all of the human space
flight stuff engineers astronauts when
you look at the astronaut office even
now when i left uh in 2015 it was still
at about the 20-25 percent women in the
office
now i think there's roughly 40 active
astronauts and almost 40 percent are
women and that far exceeds what
you know what's happening in our
universities and the engineering
programs and that's why i think the one
piece of advice i would have
for and maybe it's more for us women who
have already experienced this is that we
need to be present we need to be there
encouraging the young women in middle
school so as they continue on they need
to see
i think girls are kind of see it be it
right
and we should get you on star talk well
i'd be happy to be on stream
let's see
okay
so thank you
it's huge isn't it and um and it's just
so that and young boys too need to know
it's like the rocket ship doesn't care
if you're a boy or girl
right we do that kind of ourselves and
and my biggest wait wait wait there's
another another important point
which you hinted at but i want to drive
home
it is one thing for other for
up-and-coming girls to see successful
women in these roles
it's also important for up-and-coming
boys to see that yes that is almost
equally as important because then they
will realize that they could be entering
a field where this is fully
participatory across the spectrum
and that that's part of the forcing of
what needs to happen in the society if
we're truly to have a representative
world totally agree and it's why i mean
i'm hugely thankful to my
the male leadership i had in nasa for uh
you know encouraging
you know the growth kind of the
diversity that showed up in that that
time frame as well and yeah i mean i
might i have a son he's 19 years old now
i don't think it crosses his mind
um to consider oh why is that girl doing
this versus you know it and and i love
that i love it are you are you friends
with kathy i am did you come up with her
yeah yeah we we've served on several
boards together she's she became a good
friend and yeah that this is also a
shuttle uh astronaut jordan and she went
on uh to she became head of noah i think
yeah she had quite a career like usually
say i'm done as an astronaut now you're
out to pasture no this just kept going
and so it's great to take this great
like the marianas trench thing too
oh my gosh you guys are out of control
oh yeah i i i i know astronauts too you
ever heard of a buzz aldrin oh yes we
[Laughter]
jordan we had jordan on a pro on a show
where we had buzz aldrin as one of our
guests so that's just one experience
that he'd never let anybody forget
i i i text these guys all the time
yeah so we all we're all friends with
astronauts
all right so you got more questions
jordan from our patreonics i do this
this is from miss magoo from canada
all right a question about coming back
to earth for nicole
what goes on inside the body when you
experience a massive change like going
from space to earth i live with a
nervous system disorder called pots and
i understand astronauts can experience
something similar upon returning to
earth for example fainting trouble being
upright
yeah great question you know
one thing we all have in common when we
come back to earth whether we're there
for a short period of time or a long
period of time is you feel really heavy
this whole 1g thing that's that's
putting a lot of load on us every day we
just kind of take it for granted right
we don't really consider it let me tell
you it everybody feels heavy but yeah
you know the whole vestibular system
that whole thing in our bodies that help
us stand up straight know which way is
up down you know it gets a little wacky
and little hairs in our ears that help
control that or
monitor it for us um need to be
recalibrated really once once you get
back in gravity and
plus don't you break a lot of glasses
because you drink water and you just let
go of it and it falls to the ground and
you forget you're no longer in zero g
there it is there's there's i mean
there's the oh my gosh i was just in
space an hour ago and there's the why
don't things just float in front of me
like they
do
it's funny though our brains and our
bodies are so cool they adapt
so quickly both ways i mean really in
the grand scheme of you know getting to
space and
figuring out how to float and move in
three dimensions and fly you know like
we all dream about doing and then coming
back to earth and
and moving and functioning and being
healthy the way
you know we were before going to space
well how about in the condition that the
um
the woman describes uh if did are there
any musculoskeletal coordination issues
you have to contend with when you come
back other than just what's up and down
and left and right yeah well and and
and i think some of that comes from kind
of that spatial
um
you know orientation that we have is
that you know which way should i move
and
and when you're in space your body's
floating and you can just offload all of
that but when you come back to earth now
you have to be in control of it you have
to think about holding your head up i
mean our heads are heavy and so now i'm
like i didn't have to do that for six
months now i got to hold it up you know
i haven't even thought about that
so you so the astronauts come back the
head is just dangerous
[Laughter]
the original bobble heads are astronauts
but there is i think there's there's a
lot of that that same kind of thing and
if we were in space and we didn't
exercise the two hours a day that we do
because of the accelerated bone and
muscle loss because our bodies figure
out oh my gosh i don't need those bones
and muscles to function in microgravity
so i'm not going to waste any energy
maintaining them we are having to
counteract that all the time
okay so it's the is the prior knowledge
that yes you have to keep your
musculoskeletal system tuned
so that when you come back you're not
just this pile of goo that collapses on
the ground
yeah okay all right jordan keep him
coming
this is uh from taylor prim
taylor wants to know what do you think
art can do to help make a science or
science itself more accessible for the
blind i'm trying to get a degree in
astronomy and i'm blind most of the
tools the school uses for teaching
students is inaccessible wow
wow you know i was just on a call
yesterday with
some of the folks at huntsville that run
space camp
it's huntsville alabama alabama they
they run space camp and they have every
summer they have
at the end of summer beginning of the
school year they have a camp where all
of the kids are blind or really um you
know
have trouble seeing i mean it's it's and
i i struggle with that i'm like how
they have
created an environment around these kids
where it's not just
you know the procedures that are in
braille or the screens have bigger
writing on them
but they've they've put them into in the
environment a way where through their
other senses they're experiencing the
whole
you know um
world of being in mission control of
being a crew member um through those
different so somebody thought about
somebody clearly i actually thought i
encourage you to go you know go check
this out i'm sure the people i did not
know about this this is brilliant
talk about what they've done it was just
incredible to me and i think art as a
way it allows us
to use those other senses right to
create something like i always imagine
like these hubble images we're looking
at them we're seeing them the colors you
know those colors we put into these
images they are works of art and yet we
could create
a structure out of that we could almost
like a textured map that would give you
a sense of that same thing we see in the
colors but through the touch of that uh
of that scene or what we're seeing in
the night sky just with our naked eye
interesting so is this is this a
well-known program i mean
i didn't know anything about it okay i
was so excited to hear about it because
okay um and then to to hear some of the
the comments from the the students that
were participating
i mean first of all they were they were
just there was like this joy of being
with other people that were experiencing
it in the same way they were
and being able to share that and then
really just actively being able to
engage
in what every other kid that goes to
space camp engages in but but through
different means art is not only a
two-dimensional phenomenon right i mean
sculpting and and so much else yes yes
exactly the acoustic sculptures that's
right that's right there's more going on
i went down to space camp a few years
ago and a fun fact is even a 40 year old
who goes to space camp can find himself
nauseous for over an hour
oh okay yes that's right you don't need
to be cited to feel nauseous and throw
up
that is true
yeah excellent so jordan keep going
yes uh this is from woody and what he
wants to know what part of space travel
could be better we've been doing it for
over 50 years we've spent trillions on
it so why can't they keep the cabin
pressure constant enough that kids ear
holes don't explode on a ninety dollar
three hour trip to on a dang boeing
oh my gosh i you know i loved every
minute of i would have to say you know
my first space flight we didn't have the
cupola module that um
kind of earth-facing bay window
observatory um on this on the space
station
and on my second flight we did
and i'll tell you what what could make
it better is just more more windows
bigger windows let me look back at earth
let me look out to deep space let me
have the opportunity to just experience
everything around me from every angle
and by the way the the the boeing 787
has larger windows
relative to other uh craft and by the
way the size of the window is a is an
important structural issue because the
window is not holding the plane together
the rest of the plane is holding the
plane together so the more windows you
have the you know there's a compromise
there so
uh now how about the pressure what is
the pressure inside the international
space station
relative to what you might experience in
an airplane um well um probably better
because we keep the pressure inside the
space station at sea level pressure so
what we do are normally you know
experiencing yeah it's very nice very
comfortable yeah wow yeah because on an
airplane they they drop the pressure a
little bit just because if you keep the
same pressure as sea level they have to
make the structure of the plane stronger
to accommodate the pressures against the
very low pressure at 30 40 000 feet so
fascinating
so they cheap out that's why yeah
eventually
that's not how i said it jordan you're
you're a little bit loosey-goosey and
you end up buying three tangrays and
tonics they do that because you don't
want to
yeah in fact under with the lower air
pressure the alcohol has a stronger
effect on you and so
yeah yeah i mean yeah and also is that
why i i weep at any pixar
i've teared up in some movies that i
don't think i would have teared up at
sea level uh well you gotta have
somebody look into that
oh yeah old yeller at sea level driving
i saw bailly
babe with the pig i teared up at the end
of that that was so that was so so
tender i first saw that on on an
airplane
but hey we got time for like one or two
more questions let's let's keep going
great this is uh from zen's cootie bence
hello neil and nicole what was the
strangest habit you had to get used to
while being in space many thanks from
hungary oh cool strangest habit
um it's strange but wonderful
well it's floating it is strange i mean
it's funny how now i look at my friends
i live vicariously through them floating
through the space station but that's a
that's a pretty strange thing to
easy habit to kick though
one of the easiest what are the easiest
habits to kick but you want more so
would you find yourself now that you're
retired would you go up on one what they
used to call the vomit comet you know
the the trajectory planes that simulate
zero g okay would you do that just to
get a little a little piece of the
action again yeah i just did it recently
actually it was really wonderful got to
take my family with me was on the plane
with charlie duke which was outstanding
nice you know if you want to throw
astronaut names out there
and
it was like
i mean it just see jordan what you made
her do you made her name drop an apollo
astronaut
yeah jordan come on why did you make it
that was so much fun
it's not a competition guys
and just gracefully float and
appreciate it yeah
okay but uh okay you can tell us and we
won't tell anybody except for all the
people that are half a million viewers
yeah uh so how quickly did you barf in
zero g oh my gosh i didn't i did not
fall i was so fortunate so for you a
lion you are lying
i wanted to barf but couldn't i so
wished that i could have thrown up and i
think i would have felt so much better
on that you know those first few hours
but it didn't happen wow
okay
i'm not lying to you man i had what
plenty of crew members who didn't
either yeah okay okay well i don't want
to end on a barf question so okay so
jordan last question give me one more
you know last question here and you know
a lot of people want to know about the
overview effect and i know we talked a
little bit about it but maddie fontaine
wants to know from minnesota
what would be the effect on society if
every person got the chance to see earth
oh beautiful question to end this on and
unfortunately nicole you got to
be a little fast in the answer so what
can you tell us um it would be
i think it would be one of the most
wonderful things most positive uplifting
life-changing things for everyone
and would it be the end of all wars and
things
i'd be out of a job i'd be out of a job
i don't know it would be better
everything would be better
okay you can't you can't experience that
and not have it
affect you
overview is back to you i like that
crewmates not passengers idea i think
that's that's that's a nice way that's a
nice way to put it
okay so here's here
here's i'm going to give
edgar mitchell the last word in this
agreement apollo 14. you ready
here it goes
you develop an instant global
consciousness a people orientation and
intense dissatisfaction with the state
of the world and a compulsion to do
something about it from out there on the
moon international politics looks so
petty you want to grab a politician by
the scuff of the neck and drag him a
quarter million miles out and say look
at that you son of a [ __ ]
nicole do we have agreement on that
[Laughter]
all right guys nicole thanks for
spending time out of your busy life with
us on star talk and our fan base and
just keep it going uh keep inspiring us
all in everything you do
and and how do we find you on social
media uh you can find me uh at uh
astro underscore nicole on
astro nicole you've got it and we've got
your new book coming out and who's the
publisher of that um hachette books with
seal press yes okay excellent we'll be
looking for it thank you and all right
and jordan always good to have you man i
missed you throughout all covet don't be
a stranger next year
just call me just call me neil i'm
buying the phone i
need this you're waiting for the phone
but it'll hang up on you with buzz calls
all right
which he does regularly regularly we
talk about anything
right this has been star talk cosmic
queries the overview edition neil
degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
you